es war eine gigantische asteroiden
explosion über der beringsee
sie hatte die 10 fache stärke der
atombombe von hiroshima wäre dieser
brocken in einer stadt niedergegangen
wäre sie zerstört worden alle einwohner
wären umgekommen oder noch schlimmer er
wäre in die beringsee gestürzt um warum
das so verheerend wäre
alle infos jetzt mal weg zum science
fiction hier gibt's täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nichts los geht's
die schlagen riesige asteroiden auf der
erde ein oder explodieren in der
atmosphäre schiller bis 2013 war die
letzte große explosion und jetzt schon
wieder damals wurden rund 7000 gebäude
beschädigt und 1500 menschen verletzt
die sprengkraft jetzt 173 kg das
zehnfache der hiroshima-bombe
durchmesser wahrscheinlich zehn meter
geschwindigkeit unfassliche 115000 200
kilometer pro stunde und nur weil der
asteroid etwas mehr als 25 kilometer
über der menschenleeren wäre sie
explodiert ist kam niemand zu schaden
es handelt sich um die zweite schwerste
derartige explosion in diesem
jahrhundert das ganze geschah bereits im
dezember niemand hatte es bemerkt und
das zeigt auch dass selbst mega
explosion niemand ausfallen riesiger
region sind einfach ungewohnt oder
einfach mehr wie rund 70 prozent der
erde selbst große einschläge fallen dort
nicht auf und aufgrund der zentrischen
wellen entstehung gibt es auch keine
großen tsunami ist wie wir hier
letztlich berichtet haben da der
einschlag punktförmig ist verlieren sie
ihre energie sehr schnell und sind ab
einer entfernung des anschlags von mehr
als 20 kilometern vom festland mit aller
wahrscheinlichkeit gar nicht mehr
gefährlich etwas ganz anderes könnte die
furchtbare konsequenz seien mehrere
hundert megatonnen wasser werden durch
den einschlag bis in die stratosphäre
katapultiert anteil davon sehr schnell
über den eintritts weg des asteroiden
weil er hier ein teil vakuum
zurückgelassen hat das jetzt das wasser
ansaugt in der stratosphäre kann das
wasser dann monate oder jahre verbleiben
und heizt dann den treibhauseffekt auf
der erde noch weiter an das wäre die
schlimmste katastrophe und könnte zu
millionen toten führen sprich ein
einschlag direkt in eine millionenstadt
wie
und zwar verheerend und würde sie
wahrscheinlich wie eine atombombe
vernichten einen einschlag in einen
ozean aber könnte weitaus verheerender
sein weil er auswirkungen auf die ganze
erde haben würde und eins wird durch
diese explosion klar wir sind einem
asteroiden dauerregen ausgesetzt und
wenn man sich dann die karte der nasa
ansieht mit den größeren asteroiden die
in die erdatmosphäre eingedrungen sind
dann bekommt man schon ein wenig bammel
wie viele das sind und man sieht dass
die aktuelle explosion wirklich mit der
explosion über täler bis zu den beiden
größten gehört die bisher festgestellt
wurden wahnsinn und es zeigt auch wie
dringend wir etwas gegen hast du jeden
tun müssen und die nasa wird jetzt aktiv
premiere nasa villazon aus der bahn
werfen dafür je klicken anschauen und
abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran